avec arnaud benedetti il est avec nous
par téléphone arnaud men inédit merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors le premier ministre on le disait
doit présenter la phase 2 du
déconfinement dans moins d'une heure les
attentes sont nombreuses notamment dans
les secteurs du tourisme ou de la
restauration selon vous la france ne
peut plus se permettre d'attendre
écoutez ce confort c'est qu'il y à une
pression de la société une pression des
opérateurs économiques pour mettre fin
rapidement maintenant à cette épreuve
quand même que constitue le confirmant
on sait que les chiffres de l'économie
sont tous points extrêmement inquiétant
avec un taux de chômage qui a bondi avec
un certain nombre d'opérateurs
économiques qui dans différents secteurs
vont se retrouver en très grande
difficulté dans les semaines et les mois
qui viennent dont kylie a manifestement
aujourd'hui un grande une grande
pression une grande demande qui
s'exprime et on peut imaginer que les
annonces du premier ministre vont et et
annoncent qu'ils vont permettre de
desserrer l'étau d'autant plus que la
circulation aujourd'hui du virus
apparaît relativement vaincu
relativement contenu du coup on peut
dire que maintenant c'est davantage la
crise économique qui est dans l'esprit
de l'exécutif plutôt que la crise
sanitaire
il est clair que l'on rentre dorénavant
dans la phase 2 de cette séquence assez
extraordinaire entre guy n'écrit plus
info vécu c'est à dire qu'il va falloir
gérer les conséquences à la fois
économique et social et y compris
d'ailleurs politique de cette épidémie
c'est certainement la partie la plus
difficile auquel aujourd'hui l'exécutif
est confronté et on peut imaginer que
cela aura une traduction politique dans
les semaines qui viennent pour affronter
cette épreuve comment est ce que ça
pourrait se traduire justement vous
parlez de traduction politique
bon d'abord il ya la queue savoir
qu'elle travaille nous politique un que
décidera d'adopter le président de la
république
en l'occurrence on a vu que son sens
vocabulaire politique avait
considérablement évolué au fur et à
mesure du déroulé de cette crise il a
intégré métaboliser un certain nombre de
notions qui ne faisaient pas
automatiquement partie de son
vocabulaire politique quand celle de
souveraineté par exemple est également
la dimension sociale donc déjà ça c'est
un premier point le deuxième point c'est
de savoir avec quelles femmes et
quelques hommes
il va éventuellement reconstruire ce
logiciel politique us est un secret pour
personne qu'un certain nombre de rumeurs
de bruits circulent sur un éventuel
changement de premier ministre
est ce que ce changement de premier
ministre sid a lieu traduire à un
changement de cap politique en général
un changement de premier ministre pour
qu'il y ait du sens au toit change doit
en effet illustré et démontrer qu'on
chat en confiance le corps de cap
politique ce sont toutes les questions
qui vont se poser très rapidement à
l'exécutif avec une attaque importante
qui sera la tenue du second tour des
élections municipales on peut penser que
jusqu'au second tour des élections
municipales il ne se passera rien mais à
partir de second tour des élections
municipales c'est à dire à partir du 28
juin
les cartes politiques seront
vraisemblement redistribuer d'autant
plus qu'à l'intérieur de la majorité on
voit qu'aujourd'hui cette majorité de
plus en plus difficile à tenir donc il
va falloir que le président n'a subi que
l'on se définit au politique extrêmement
fort alors pour revenir à cette face de
lui des confinement on se souvient
certains avaient dénoncé des mesures
trop tardives au début de l'épidémie
d'autres avancent qu'il aurait fallu des
confiné plus rapidement finalement cette
crise est ce qu'elle révèle la lenteur
des institutions face à l'urgence ou
plutôt il ya un gouvernement qui fait
preuve de prudence
l'élève vraisembablement la lenteur de
la lapd heures la lenteur de l'état qui
est lié à la nature même de notre de
notre organisation administrative
ce ne sont pas tant les institutions qui
cause problème en occurrence l
institution assure une stabilité au
régime qui est extrêmement importante
dans les circonstances que
vivant mais il est depuis le début on
était vraiment vraiment un défaut de
réactivité à défaut d interactivité au
début de la crise mais la question du
déconfinement elle est liée aussi à la
volonté du premier ministre depuis le
début d'étape différentes d'ailleurs de
celle du président de la république
d'avoir un rythme extrêmement prudent
dans les mesures opératoire permettant
de déconfinement ne serait ce que pour
éviter vraisemblablement que le deuxième
vague qui surviennent
donc il y avait cent dans les deux
aspects qui entre en compte dans la
stratégie qui était celle que le tpr
alors on le disait un une phase ii pour
répondre à des questions économiques
mais aussi sociales
à la question de la réouverture des
écoles et notamment des lycées les
épreuves de bac est ce que là aussi il
ya urgence est ce que c'est souhaitable
que ces lycées rouge selon vous écoutez
le regard du calendrier aujourd'hui
scolaire on peut se poser la question de
l'année fait chuter de réouvrir les lits
faits puisque on est au début juin et
que ça jeu on sera en fin d'année
scolaire
on a bien vu que depuis le début sur
cette question du redémarrage de la vie
scolaire il ya eu un certain nombre de
tensions qui se sont en tout cas posé au
niveau du ministère l'éducation
nationale dispose encore incertaine en
plus de questions on compte 1 à laquelle
un canton au problème de la tenue du
baccalauréat en tout cas pour l'oral de
français
ce sont des récurrences yeux que nous
devrions avoir par une multi viennent
merci beaucoup arnaud benedetti d'avoir
répondu à une question je rappelle que
vous êtes très d'acteurs en chef de la
revue politique et parlementaire